ORIGINALS THE ILLEGAL INVASION
AVAILABLE NOW ON FOX NATION.
BRIAN: LET’S BRING IN LARA TRUMP
ON THIS SHE KNEW ONE OF THE
THEMES ADMINISTRATION
FATHER-IN-LAW WAS ART PA OF AND
SHE WAS DEFINITELY PART OF HIS
RE-ELECTION EFFORTS WAS ABOUT
THE BORDER.
IT DOESN’T TAKE EVERY SINGLE
TIME YOU BRING UP A PROBLEM WITH
THE BORDER FOR MAYORKAS TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THEY SAY THIS IS A PROBLEM THEY
INHERITED.
DO YOU THINK THAT’S TRUE?
>> OH, IT’S PATENTLY FALSE.
IT’S RIDICULOUS TO EVER SUGGEST
THAT.
IN FACT I SAY IT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY GIVEN A GIFT
WITH THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
DONALD TRUMP HAD SET IT UP SO
WELL FOR THEM THAT ALL THEY HAD
TO DO WAS SIT BACK AND DO
NOTHING.
NOT TOUCH A THING, KEEP THE
POLICIES IN PLACE THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAD PUT THERE,
CONTINUE AND FINISH BUILDING THE
WALL.
AND WE WOULD NOT SEE THAT WE
HAVE OVER A MILLION MIGRANTS
THAT WE KNOW OF, GUYS THAT HAVE
COME OVER OUR BORDER ILLEGALLY
MONTH AFTER MONTH WE SEE THAT
RISE AND THERE IS ONE REASON FOR
IT, IT IS BECAUSE JOE BIDEN,
KAMALA HARRIS, CAMPAIGNED ON THE
IDEA THAT WE WERE GOING TO HAVE
AN OPEN BORDER IF THEY WERE
ELECTED.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE HEARD THAT
AND THEY CONTINUE TO COME OVER
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
WHAT A RIDICULOUS COPOUT BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO EVER
SUGGEST SUCH A THING.
RACHEL: WHY DO YOU THINK THEY
WANT AN OPEN BORDER?
>> WELL, I THINK YOU HAVE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT SCENARIOS THERE.
MAYBE THE REASON IS THAT THEY
KNOW THAT THEY ARE FAILING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN MANY WAYS.
THEY KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
A REALLY HARD TIME IN 22 IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTION THE.
THEY KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
A REALLY TOUGH 24 POSSIBLE
RE-ELECTION IF THEY BOTH DECIDE
TO GO FOR IT.
MAYBE THEY THINK THAT THEY BRING
MIGRANTS OVER THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND, I DON’T KNOW, WE
DON’T HAVE ANY VOTER I.D. LIKE
THEY WANT.
THEY WANT TO FEDERALIZE THE
ELECTIONS WITH HR-1.
FORTUNATELY THAT DIDN’T GO
THROUGH.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AS TO WHY THEY WOULD
WANT TO DO THIS.
BUT, TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
IT’S VERY SUSPICIOUS THAT THIS
IS THEIR WAY TO WIN ELECTIONS IN
THE FUTURE BECAUSE, IF WE HAD A
FREE AND FAIR ELECTION.
AND EVERY LEGAL CITIZEN GOT TO
VOTE.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE VERY
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE POLICIES
OF THE DEMOCRAT PARTY JOE BIDEN
AND KAMALA HARRIS AND IT WILL BE
VERY HARD FOR THEM TO WIN
ELECTIONS.
STEVE: LARA, I DON’T KNOW IF YOU
WERE WATCHING EARLIER IN THE
PROGRAM WE TOLD A COUPLE
WHISTLEBLOWERS COME FORWARD,
THEY HAD BEEN VOLUNTEERING AT
THE CHILD MIGRANT FACILITY IN
FORT BLISS DOWN IN TEXAS.
AS IT TURNS OUT, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAS TELLING
EVERYBODY THAT WAS WORKING
THERE, HEY, WE GOT TO DOWN PLAY
THIS SITUATION.
TURNED OUT IT WAS A SUPER
SPREADER EVENT.
BUT THEY FELT LIKE WELL, IF THAT
GETS OUT.
THAT’S GOING TO BE BAD FOR ALL
OF US BECAUSE THEY WERE GOING TO
HAVE BAD PUBLICITY, AND SO NOW,
YOU KNOW, IT’S LAID BEAR.
THEY WERE TRYING TO KEEP WHAT
WAS GOING ON WITH THE CHILDREN
AT THAT FACILITY A SECRET.
AND THEY DID.
UNTIL THE WHISTLEBLOWERS CAME
FORWARD, LARA.
>> YEAH.
WELL, AND THIS IS PAR FOR THE
COURSE.
YOU KNOW, FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
REMEMBER, IN THE VERY BEGINNING,
WHEN WE SAW, WE GOT THOSE
PICTURES AND VIDEOS, FINALLY, OF
THE OVERCROWDED FACILITIES, THEY
DIDN’T WANT THE PRESS THERE.
THEY DIDN’T WANT THE MEDIA
THERE.
THEY TRIED TO KEEP EVERYBODY
OUT.
THEY HAVE TRIED TO DOWN PLAY
THIS EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
BUT I WANT TO SAY KUDOS TO
GOVERNOR ABBOTT FOR FINALLY
TAKING CONTROL OF THIS
SITUATION.
IF WE CANNOT RELY ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY TO SECURE OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT WILL COME DOWN TO THE STATES
HAVING TO DO IT.
AND THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT HAVE
YOU SEEN HAPPEN WITH GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT.
I MEAN, IT’S A PREPOSTEROUS THAT
WE FOUND OURSELVES IN THIS
PLACE.
BUT IT IS THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT
CONTINUES TO CARE MORE ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO DON’T EVEN LIVE IN
AMERICA THAN THEY DO ABOUT
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
RACHEL: ALL RIGHT.
THANKTHANK YOU, LARA.
THERE IS A LOT OF THROIMENTS